ja meine damen und herren aber vor allen
dingen lieber herr bundeskanzler lieber
olaf scholz und die jenigen die
dazugehören herr schmidt der zukünftige
chef des bundes kann der schon der chef
des bundeskanzleramt ist der
noch nicht genannte glaube ich
regierungssprecher
die staatsminister hier im kanzleramt
ich möchte sie ganz herzlich begrüßen
und das tue ich auch im namen all derer
die vorher diese funktion eingenommen
hatten ich konnte heute weil ich nicht
mehr mitglied des deutschen bundestages
bin olaf scholz noch nicht persönlich
gratulieren und möchte dass deshalb auf
diesem wege nachholen herzlichen
glückwunsch sehr geehrter bundeskanzler
hieber olaf scholz ich weiß aus eigenem
erleben dass es ein bewegender moment
ist in dieses amt gewählt zu werden sie
eher an vielleicht dass es eine
spannende erfüllende aufgabe ist auch
eine fordernde aufgabe aber wenn man sie
mit freude an geht dann ist es
vielleicht auch eine der schönsten
aufgaben die es gibt für dieses land
verantwortung zu tragen ich wünsche
ihnen von herzen alles gute bei dieser
arbeit und immer eine glückliche hand
für unser land und diese wünsche
erstrecken sich auch auf das ganze team
corona bedingt sind wir heute in einem
sehr kleinen kreis hier versammelt als
ich damals von gerd schröder diese
aufgabe übernommen habe stand die
gesamte süd treppe voller
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter die uns
jetzt zum teil auch zu hören und ich
darf ihnen sagen sie werden hier eine
mannschaft vorfinden die voller
leidenschaft voller engagement
arbeitet tag und wenn es sein muss auch
nachts die immer einsatzbereit ist
motiviert ist gute ideen hat fachkundig
ist und das gilt für alle das gilt vom
innen schutz bis zu allen referenten
gruppenleitern und abteilungsleitern das
gilt von denen die in der küche arbeiten
bis zur registratur der poststelle und
in vielen vielen aufgaben die hier
einander greifen müssen wer sich einmal
ins kanzleramt
bewegt auch als mitarbeiter oder
mitarbeiterin der weiß was politik
bedeutet nämlich dass man morgens wenn
man aufsteht und hier zum dienst geht
nicht weiß was bis zum abend passiert
ist das ist immer dazu kommen kann dass
man auch auf ganz neue herausforderungen
acht muss ich weiß dass sie mit großer
motivation jetzt an die arbeit gehen und
deshalb
nehmen sie dieses haus in besitz und
arbeiten sie mit ihm zum besten unseres
landes das ist mein wunsch und ich
wünsche ihnen dabei alles gute
[Applaus]
ja sind wir live dabei im berliner
kanzleramt das ist die amtsübergabe die
bisherige hausherrin angela merkel tritt
von der bühne ab und ihr folgt der neue
bundeskanzler kohl die bundeskanzlerin
ich möchte mich sehr für ihre arbeit in
den letzten 16 jahren bedanken ich
glaube dass man sehr genau und sehr
präzise sagen kann das war eine große
zeit in der sie kanzlerin dieses landes
waren und sie haben auch großartiges
bewegt wir haben viele viele
herausforderungen zu bewältigen gehabt
aber es waren immer wieder auch große
krisen die auf uns zugekommen sind
manche haben wir gemeinsam
durchgestanden in unterschiedlichen
funktionen aber auch ich als mitglied
des von ihnen geführten kabinetts ich
erinnere nur an die finanzkrise
2008/2009 hier in einer an die großen
herausforderungen die mit der flucht
migration 215 folgende verbunden waren
und natürlich jetzt wieder die große
ökonomische soziale
herausforderung die mit der kroner
pandemie verbunden ist das hat
zusammengeschweißt und das waren nicht
nur diese ereignisse und zwischen uns
hat immer eine sehr vertrauensvolle art
der zusammenarbeit existiert das glaube
ich ist auch gut weil es zeigt dass wir
eine starke leistungsfähige demokratie
sind in der es einen großen konsens gibt
zwischen den verantwortlichen
demokratinnen und demokraten und es wird
auch in zukunft weiter unser stärke
ausmachen trotzdem sie haben dieses land
geprägt und auch diese regierung und
auch dieses haus und deshalb glaube ich
sagen zu können ist es schon irgendwie
was besonderes und ich will gerne
anknüpfen an die wie soll man das sagen
nordostdeutsche mentalität die da bisher
geherrscht hat so viel wird sich nicht
ändern
ich glaube dass wir alle hier
zurückgreifen können wie sie das schon
gesagt haben auf ganz großartige arbeit
die viele geleistet haben großartige
arbeit von den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern hier im haus und das ist
mir auch bisher schon sehr klar geworden
in den verantwortlichkeiten die ich
bisher hatte und deshalb freue ich mich
auf die enge zusammenhang danke sagen
möchte ich nicht nur ihnen sondern auch
all den anderen die hier an
verantwortlicher stelle gesessen haben
und gewirkt haben und die mit ihnen hier
versammelt sind auch da ist viel an
kooperationen und zusammenarbeit in den
letzten jahren gewesen und daran
anzuknüpfen darauf aufzubauen das wird
mir jedenfalls eine große ehre sein ich
finde es ist etwas ganz besonderes
bundeskanzler dieser republik zu sein es
ist eine große herausforderung
ich bin sehr dankbar dass ich nun von
den bürgerinnen und bürgern dieses
landes und vom deutschen bundestag den
auftrag gekriegt habe das zu machen dass
wir so lange so viele gemeinsame
erfahrung sammeln könnten das wird mir
dabei helfen schönen dank mal nochmal
für ihre arbeit
ja und noch mal an die mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiter denen heute nicht versammelt
sein können aber die uns zuhören den
streams und den verschiedenen büros
gerichtet danke für das was sie bisher
geleistet haben danke für das was sie
leisten werden ich baue darauf und
setzte darauf und wir wissen dass der
übergang den wir jetzt hier miteinander
vollziehen einer ist mitten in einer
großen nicht abgeschlossenen krise das
setzt kontinuität und gemeinschaft
voraus und ich gehe davon aus dass uns
das auch gelingt vermerk und nicht
wissen dass wir die krone pandemie nur
bekämpfen können in dem sich viele
impfen und lassen und viele
auffrischungsimpfungen holen indem wir
vorsichtig sind das gehört dazu und
deshalb ist es auch richtig dass unsere
zusammenkunft hier so etwas
begrenzt ist was die zahl der real
anwesenden betrifft das wir masken
tragen wenn wir am platz sitzen das ist
die grundlage dafür dass das gut
gelingen kann ich jedenfalls bin sehr
dankbar für das was wir bisher gemacht
haben ich freue mich auf die neue
aufgabe ich freue mich auf alle die hier
arbeiten und es soll ein guter aufbruch
werden für unser land ich will
jedenfalls alles dafür tun schönen dank
ja soweit aus dem bundeskanzleramt die
übergabe des staffelstabes von bisher
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel an den
neuen an den neunten bundeskanzlerin
bundesrepublik deutschland olaf scholz
und jetzt gucken wir mal weiter der frau
bundeskanzlerin
ich spreche heute vertretend halt für
die belegschaft die ja leider nur am
bildschirm zu schauen kann wir haben
halt besondere zeiten aber man war es in
den letzten 16 jahren schon mal anders
in den letzten 16 jahren haben sie nicht
nur dieses haus geprägt sondern das
ganze land europa und die welt wir als
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter hätten
uns durchaus mal ein paar ruhige jahre
gewünscht vielleicht auch mal ein
altmodisches sommerloch aber man kann ja
nun mal nicht alles haben ihre abends
zeit bundeskanzler scholz hat es gerade
angesprochen auch von vielen krisen
geprägt wir hatten die finanzkrise wir
hatten die flüchtlinge wir hatten
terrorismus afghanistan corona in all
diesen jahren in all diesen besonderen
situationen waren sie trotzdem
stets unprätentiös unaufgeregt und ruhig
sie waren stets nager hatten ein nettes
wort und einen gruß auch für die kleinen
lichter und das kann ich aus eigener
erfahrung beurteilen sie haben jeden auf
augenhöhe behandelt dass es nicht
selbstverständlich
wir danken ihnen und dem kanzleramtschef
minister braun
für das entgegengebrachte vertrauen und
die gute zusammenarbeit in den
vergangenen jahren und wünschen ihnen
für ihren weiteren lebensweg alles gute
sie sagten ja mal sie wollen jetzt ein
wenig schlafen und dann mal sehen wie es
weitergeht wir hoffen dass sie auch in
zukunft etwas zeit fürs wandern wieder
finden und haben dann natürlich dran
gedacht und möchten ihn im anschluss
eine kleinigkeit dazu mit auf den weg
geben und auch für sie professor braun
auch wenn sie im anschluss sozusagen
wieder im bundestag etwas aktiver sind
als als vielleicht erhofft wie auch
immer auch ihnen unsere hoffnung dass
sie vielleicht etwas mehr zeit für ihre
hobbys in zukunft haben auch für sie
haben eine kleinigkeit noch vorbereitet
gab
sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler unseren
ganz herzlichen glückwunsch im namen
aller kolleginnen und kollegen dieses
hauses zur wahl zum neuen bundeskanzler
der bundesrepublik deutschland
sie übernehmen mit dem heutigen tage ein
besonderes haus
wie es so schön heißt niemand ist
zufällig ins kanzleramt gekommen
es ist schon eine ausgewählte und
besondere mannschaft die sich hier
erwartet keiner partei verpflichtet
sondern dem land gut vernetzt und
sachkundig um ihnen die bestmögliche
information und beratung zu liefern
ihnen herr bundeskanzler und ihnen herr
minister schmit er zukünftig unserer
dienststellenleiter wir wünschen ihnen
alles erdenklich gute für die
bevorstehenden aufgaben
sie können sich sicher sein dass die
kolleginnen und kollegen des
bundeskanzleramt ist ihres amtes
stets treu und loyal mit besten kräften
und gewissen hin zur seite stehen
herzlich willkommen noch mal und wir
freuen uns auf die zusammenarbeit danke
also weiß jetzt aus berlin das war noch
mal der sprecher des personalrates im
kanzleramt er hat noch mal herzlich
willkommen gesagt und auf wiedersehen
und wird kriegt angela merkel auch von
ihm noch ein wunderschönen blumenstrauß
da hat sie heute schon ganz viele
bekommen
ja
ja wie ist denn das jetzt eigentlich in
berlin frage ich mal unseren
hauptstadtkorrespondenten werk joachim
von fallois also die eingehen die
anderen kommen also im prinzip sind die
ein jetzt im amt also man muss dann
nicht mehr sagen die ehemalige die
geschäftsführende bundeskanzlerin
sondern die neuen posten ab jetzt gilt
es nett die amtsübergabe vollziehen
sicher noch an diesen nachmittag in den
einzelnen ressorts
es ist verfassungsrechtlich so dass mit
dem erhalt der ernennungsurkunde durch
den bundespräsidenten wird der
bundeskanzler zum bundeskanzler ist es
nicht der eid im parlament der hätte
auch später geleistet werden können
sondern es ist diese urkunde und die
ernennung durch den herrn
bundespräsidenten das gilt auch für die
minister insofern sind sie schon ins im
amt wenn sie jetzt hier die amtsübergabe
machen und angela merkel ist seit dem
heutigen tage die ehemalige
bundeskanzlerin und olaf scholz ab
dieser sekunde daneben auch der hausherr
im kanzleramt aber ich habe es vorhin
schon mal angedeutet hinter diesen
schönen bildern verbirgt sich ja viel
viel mehr
abteilungsleiter eben ja ist man ein
politischer beamter und viele von denen
auch im kanzleramt die jetzt in dieser
funktion sind da gibt es nicht so
furchtbar viele die werden sicherlich in
einstweiligen ruhestand geschickt werden
denn die werden dann durch getreue des
bundeskanzlers besetzt ähnlich wird das
in den ministerien seien das ist so
üblich wie gesagt im auswärtigen amt
gilt da eine etwas andere regelung ja
und angela merkel sehen jetzt hier acht
in der tat einige der wohnung sträuße
die sie bekommen hat zusammen und geht
jetzt mit dem bundeskanzler
wahrscheinlich vor die tür und dann ist
die abfahrt und bei diesen bildern bin
ich doch noch mal erinnert an den anfang
dieses jahres auch noch einmal richtung
amerika gucken so kann man es eben auch
machen und angela merkel hat es ja
vorbildlich gemacht sie ist die erste
deutsche bundeskanzlerin die von aus
eigenen stücken gegangen ist nicht
abgewählt wurde und nicht weggeputscht
oder sonstwas wurde sondern sie hat sich
entschieden nicht noch einmal anzutreten
und sie hat seit einigen wochen olaf
scholz der ja zugegebenermaßen
vizekanzler war da war das etwas
einfacher bei vielen veranstaltungen
mitgenommen eingeführt in dieses neue
amt was er jetzt bekleidet und hatte ihn
vorgestellt das war bei manchen gar
nicht mehr nötig auch bei manchen großen
olaf scholz ist gut vernetzt in der welt
aber es ist doch schon angenehm wenn
angela merkel einem herrn beiden nochmal
persönlich vorstellt oder ein putin dass
dies sind ist dann schon ganz angenehm
auch für den neuen bundeskanzler das
kann nicht mehr vorstellen herr
professor tilman mayer von der uni bonn
kommt zurück ins studio es sind viele
schüler nette worte gesagt worden am
ende natürlich die verabschiedung aber
wir dürfen uns da natürlich nichts
vormachen der bundespräsident hatte
hatte auch gesagt das ist eine zeit des
wandels vor der wir stehen die leute
erhoffen sich erwarten führung in der
krise was ein zeichen des aufbruchs was
sind die größten unterschiede ich meine
es ist ja doch in der historische zäsur
nach zehn jahre nach 16 jahren
bundeskanzler schafft von angela merkel
jetzt mit der ampel ja das ist ein
politikwechsel der eben lange nicht
erfolgte es gab ja wirklich einen
immensen aufmarsch an versuchen sie aus
dem amt zu bringen und das gelang nicht
und erneut ist es jetzt erst gelungen
nachdem sie selber gesagt hat sie würde
nicht mehr antreten
natürlich ist es wie bei einem haus
umzug oder wohnungs neubezug dann will
man natürlich entsprechend neu
tapezieren und so weiter also es gibt
natürlich anlass das ein oder andere
anders zu machen zumal muss man sagen
diese ablösung durch den vizekanzler
natürlich ideal ist insofern als sich ja
eigentlich bestens auskennt in dem
bisherigen maschinenraum und insofern
auch wüsste wo man eigentlich neues
ansetzen muss und ich glaube in dieser
richtung will er unterwegs sein der
führung bestellt bekommt führung heißt
es etwa im wir haben das in hamburg
gesehen dass er dazu in der lage ist und
auch entsprechende zustimmung dann
daraus erwächst er hat noch nicht alle
hürden genommen auch persönliche art
comic skandal ist immer noch schwebt ein
bisschen oder schwelt auch im
hintergrund
andererseits hat man den eindruck dass
hier jemand sehr solides ins haus kommt
der das geschäft versteht und
beherrschen kann die aussenpolitische da
muss man nochmal sehen inwiefern das
gelingt auf augenhöhe mit putin jinping
und so weiter zu sein das kann man sich
im moment noch nicht so ganz vorstellen
aber ist natürlich jetzt dann fällig und
ob dann die 100 tage die sie vorhin
einsparen für mich sind das wird man
sehen vielleicht ist eben auch schon am
wochenende eine andere sache denn die
ersten reisen führen ja sand nach paris
nach brüssel